[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bear that you were fine
without it
[Music]
hey y'all some exciting news before we
dive into this episode the minimalists
are going to host a private podcast and
live stream exclusively for our patreon
supporters we're calling this ask the
minimalists anything anyone who
contributes two dollars or more over at
our patreon page can attend this special
live stream and you can't make the live
stream itself the live session the live
podcast don't worry you'll still have
access to the private video and the
private audio podcast efforts recorded
we hope to do this at least once a
quarter maybe more frequently for our
patreon supporters and please note that
none of the money from our patreon
campaign goes to our personal bank
accounts rather what we're going to do
is use these funds to build our own new
podcast studio and a film studio we're
just going to allow us to do a bunch of
really cool things like take live colors
on the air improve overall audio quality
and bring guests on the show we're also
going to hire a full time filmmaker to
create a video version of this podcast
and we also want to produce a bunch of
other meaningful video creations like
webseries TV shows interviews
documentaries video essays and more and
because we refuse to clutter our
podcasts with advertisements patreon
really is the best way for us to fund
these creative endeavors together so let
me ask you this are you willing to help
if so please become a patron today head
on over to patreon comm slash the
minimalists or you can go to our website
it's just the minimalists comm and click
on the donate button at the top we'll
put a link to that in the show notes as
well and please know that your support
is greatly appreciated together we will
create something meaningful
well hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is Joshua fields Millburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalist in Spokane yeah this is
so great we just drove over here this
morning we live right down the street in
Missoula Montana
my house is 199 miles from your Chipotle
while we're waiting for some folks to
line up and ask some questions Ryan I
had a question for you so Ryan was gone
for like the last it felt like forever
but you were in in Tokyo for what two
weeks yeah you and your partner Mariah
yeah how was it it was great man it's uh
Japan is like one of the nicest
countries I've ever been to the people
are nice yes I see my day it's both both
it's like it gives Montana run for its
money believe it or not Wow I know I did
not realize there was like amazing
landscape and mountains in Japan but
like gather or they got beat to have
everything beaches they have
snowboarding it's like it's like it's
like California but everyone speaks
Japanese so I was going to get into some
like serious questions about minimalism
but but I mean you you spent some time
in Tokyo which is it makes cities like
like New York seemed like midsize now it
like Tokyo is well it's literally well I
guess depends on what demographic you're
looking at I think like square miles
it's like the biggest city in the world
it holds the biggest city in the world
for one of those demographics okay yeah
but it literally is it's like five New
York cities and one I've noticed like
well so so around the same time that
this whole minimalism movement really
caught fire and in the late eighties
early teens here
it also has a parallel movement over in
in Japan as well and I'm really inspired
not necessarily by by Feng Shui but by
the type of minimalism that I'm into is
architecture and and bare bones I think
one of the things about minimalism for
me is the bones or the beauty of the
thing and so if you have a a beautiful
object or if you have a home that is is
beautiful without all the accoutrements
that I've noticed I noticed a lot of
that is going on in Japan right now yeah
it's
so we were in an Airbnb we actually
stayed with a couple friends so Josh
Wagner and Alexa go and I'll talk about
in the podcast before but essentially I
got a couple friends who they they teach
English online and they travel basically
every 90 days to a new country because
like their visas run out after 90 days
and it's funny because like people will
come up to me and they're like well
Colin right and your documentary he must
be a millionaire like there's only like
he could only be a millionaire to travel
like that and these guys are not
millionaires by any stretch I mean this
starving artist basically I like I was
trying not to like coin him a starving
artist but yeah I mean yeah there's a
pretty much starving artist so I told
him I was like if you ever make it over
to Tokyo they were talking about how
they might get over that way
I told him that you know Mariah now
would totally go out there and visit but
we were saying with them in an Airbnb it
was two bedrooms one bathroom and it was
super tiny I want to say like maybe 600
square feet but a big four over there
yeah yeah it was a it was very well
crafted like it was an apartment but it
you know felt like a tiny home but it
wasn't like uncomfortable to where we
were on top of each other
we couldn't like hear each other's
bathroom noises like you know it was it
was fine
but no it was it was great I was really
impressed with how all the spaces we
went to like other people's apart or
whether it was a coffee shop or a
restaurant it's amazing like what they
could fit into such a small place the
bathroom specifically it's like you walk
into this little sushi place we're like
they can even they can't even have
chairs it's one of the best sushi places
I ate when I was there they don't even
have chairs like hit the stand and eat
sushi and you're like oh they definitely
don't have a you know restroom and you
know more I was like oh the restroom and
in the guy behind the counter was like
oh yeah it's over there and I'm like oh
I like they actually like this place is
so small but they can sell the restroom
and um she went and she came back out
she was like they have like a toilet and
a sink and everything and I went in
there and it was like no bigger than
like a closet like a small small closet
but they were just able to like fit
everything and I don't know they're just
very deliberate with how they put all
their their stuff in the space that they
have so we talked to a few folks who own
tiny homes we don't have tiny houses
ourselves but we have appropriately
sized houses for us um and I mean it'd
be really I have a three-year-old now
and she is I call her hurricane Ella and
sometimes you know I can't imagine
living in a tiny home with her but I can
see one of you but I can see a time when
it would be appropriate but the thing
that I that I noticed with the people
that we talked to who lived in these
tiny homes we were recording our
documentary was you they have to make
some tough decisions with their space
they're tough at first but they're
important decisions and later on they're
like man I'm so glad that I like I it's
a weird way of forcing yourself to be
intentional it's the creative
restrictions or creative limitations
that force you to bring in only that
which is essential you know I was given
the talk earlier I was talking about the
things that I own now serve a purpose or
they bring me joy and everything else is
out of the way and I really saw that
personified in the tiny houses and it
sounds like you saw a lot of that
I mean where we were staying like they
had no choice but to do that yeah
otherwise you'd be like my neighbor that
there's the ultimate irony here the
person across the street from my house
it's like the minimalists and then the
hoarders quite literally I mean I'm not
judging them I mean literally they don't
have blinds they just have boxes stacked
up and what I've what I've come to
realize is that that's where that's the
terminus of it right now
I was a well-organized hoarder because I
collected a lot of stuff and I had an
ordinal system of boxes and bins and and
I was I was I found a way to hide my
hoarding really well and and when you
have a space like that it's much much
harder to hide the hoarding I had an
attic in a basement in a garage and a
storage locker on the edge of town
anyway welcome back to the state's Ryan
thanks man oh by the way he sent me a
picture while he was over there he had a
lot of sushi when he was there and all
well you you you won't be clapping in a
moment he sent me this picture and I was
certain he had had a stroke and my
partner Rebecca she is a registered
dietician and she was like oh he has a
facial paralysis from food poisoning and
he ate so much sushi that his left eye
just stopped working I [ __ ] you not yet
funny now it's funny now I was not
laughing at the time I will say though
like I went to the hospital and I'm
telling good it was like I would never
get that experience well first up I
never get that experience in an ER in
the States I mean like I got there and
there were just like how can we help you
and you know we'll find someone who
speaks English and then like it was
Golden Week which is like the one I want
to say like super holiday that they all
take over the ones off that week
including the ER doctors so there's like
you know sorry there's a doctor here to
look at your eyes sorry there's no
emergencies this week but they like
they went out of their way to like find
another doctor who was who was available
who spoke English I mean it was it was
really awesome and and like the doctor
eye doctor visit the eyedrops that they
gave me it was like 60 bucks I mean I
was just like no I had no insurance what
I mean I have insurance I didn't have
travel insurance because I'm like I will
not get any travel insurance but I mean
really those in travel insurance
probably cost me 60 bucks but yeah at
the end of the day it was it was like
and I'm Mariah she used to work at an
eye clinic and to see in an off to mom
to Tamala gist ophthalmologist it's like
300 50 bucks
so yeah just blew me away and yeah
especially how kind of people are over
there but anyway
well I'm glad you're back I'm glad we
are here in Spokane thank you all for
being here tonight thank you so much
we've got some fine folks getting ready
to ask some questions if you just say
what your name is and if you're from
here if you're from somewhere else and
whatever your question is we're happy to
help out I'm James I'm from Spokane how
they just wanted to say thank you Josh
Ryan for coming to Spokane oh man our
pleasure you got some time to do some
temporary depth sensory deprivation time
my question is I have a lot of stuff I'm
okay with it I'm working on getting rid
of it my problem is I have a lot of
hobbies a lot of passions and I'm trying
to minimize which passions are no longer
adding value which ones is it's time to
let go
how do I help myself it's get rid of
those so let's talk about that what what
are some of those passions like if you
were to say my my top 3 passions are
blank what are those blanks there be
auto mechanics work like on the side
okay you're passionate about working on
cars yep okay cool hunting and fishing
okay that's that's three that's not how
we chunk things together I love working
on cars along skydiving it's one passion
now give me give me two more you got
some more that's great I brew beer okay
and then I like gardening okay good deal
well I've got some good news for you you
can do all of those things you can't do
them all at once and I think that was
important for me to realize right
especially when I was trying to figure
out how do I pursue and really cultivate
a passion is a better word that I was I
would look into is is thinking about my
passions not as these exciting tasks
that always make me perpetually happy
you'll get some joy from those things
but I want to delineate hobbies from
passions in this instance for you I
think your hobbies can be your passion
and I'm totally fine with that in fact I
hope that you're passionate about your
hobbies otherwise it's a total waste of
time there I had hobbies back in June
the old my old 20s where I like I didn't
even enjoy the task you know it's like
if you have a stamp collection but you
hate stamps or they're like well it's
what I'm supposed to do and so what I
what I would encourage you to do is is
figure out what your priorities are
right now and here's the good news I
don't how are you right now James I will
be 36 on Monday oh nice we're the same
age then so what what I've learned is
that sometimes I'll be really passionate
about a thing and I can stack other
passions on top of that over time when
Ryan and I first started the minimalists
comm that was six six and a half years
ago and I up until that point I had
written a lot of fiction now that's what
my passion was just writing fiction Ryan
came to me with this idea hey man I
think some people will get value from
the story you're pretty good at writing
do you think that will translate over to
nonfiction and some of it did and that's
where it started so we started writing
essays online we didn't know it we
didn't even know it was called a blog at
the time I couldn't figure it out I
couldn't spell HTML so we tried we
figured out how to to cobble together
this
this website and we started riding on
there and after about a year we people
kept asking us about about when you guys
going to write a book you're writing all
these different essays online about
simple living can you distill this down
into one book and so eventually we did
and we wrote a book called minimalism
live a meaningful life and one of the
chapters in there is about passions and
I want to feel like I'm selling you that
book so jess if you're around here
somewhere if I could give James a copy
of minimalism live a meaningful life at
some point I'd appreciate it but um
something happened what's the sound of
one person clapping that's what I call a
faux fun daddy by the way anyway yeah so
so I've learned that we started writing
the essays then we wrote a book and then
eventually like I wanted to get back to
the writing of fiction and really what
that was was storytelling for me so I
went back and said with what fiction
what what about that really resonates
with me and it was the narrative part of
things so Ryan and I moved out to
Montana in this cabin in the middle of
nowhere and we wrote our second book
called everything that remains and it
was a memoir so it has many of the
fictive elements in it so that was a
different passion I was able to stack on
top of that there's a guy named Scott
Adams and you know who Scott Adams is
anyone here
he writes that bill Burt cartoon yeah
y'all know that one right well he talks
about skill stacking and I think of
passion it could be the same way so so
what was skill stacking he'll say you
know like with drawing for example he
draws his cartoon say I am not in the
top 1% of jewelers in the world but he
has one of the 1% of most successful
cartoons in the world well why is that
was because he has these other skills
that he's incorporated with that his
other skill is storytelling
he's not in the top 1% of that either
but he's in the top 20% of drawling top
20% of storytelling and then
business-wise he's a decent
businessperson I'm in the top 20 30 % of
of running a business and that was part
of getting those those cartoons out into
the world so not the best
businessman not the best cartoonist not
the best storyteller but you stack those
skills together you find a way to blend
them and all of a sudden you're the best
1% of the cartoon storyteller
businessmen in the world and that's why
he was so successful with that and you
also have to ask yourself some questions
why do you want to do this and the
reason I ask I ask questions like that
is sometimes you might say why I want to
make a living off of this and I always
encourage people to be careful with that
I think it's great if you can do that
but don't let money be your primary
driver for your passions and your
passion should align with your values
and your beliefs and if you can earn
some income off of that on the side
that's that's great but it becomes the
primary driver the the creativity in it
it usually not always but but quite
often gets gets painted and one last
thing is if you're 36 years old right
now you can be passionate about
something for the next 5 years and you
can be passionate about something else
that following five years and then five
years after that you might discover
there's another passion that you have
you're born to be a mechanic or a yoga
instructor or an astronaut the the truth
is there dozens it's not hundreds of
things you could be passionate about the
key is to pick one work at it hard drugs
through the drudgery and be willing to
to let go of the other things at least
temporarily so you can focus on that so
you can cultivate it into a passion
that's my short answer
man I live in Montana so there's like a
lot of things to be passionate about out
in Montana yeah
well yeah I mean it's it's uh so right
now I a longboard a snowboard I don't
have a wakeboard but I love to wakeboard
pretty much anything that has a board on
it I really like except for water
boarding
I don't not compete try it but so I got
a longboard I got snowboard mountain
bike
those are like kind of my three biggest
things that that uh the three biggest
hobbies that I have and is the mountain
bike not too bad like I got a helmet
that doubles as like my snowboarding
helmet not a ton of stuff that comes
along with that my longboard that's
pretty much all I have
again helmet doubles for that to
appreciate some like knee pads and stuff
I don't like really attempt anything too
crazy
snowboarding there's a ton of stuff that
comes with that I mean like gloves and
long johns yeah so for me like the key
with well one of the keys I guess with
like my hobbies is like I have one of
what I need so I don't have to
snowboarding jackets I don't have you
know three sets of snow pants I don't
have you know I literally have one pair
of long johns that I wear when I go when
I go snowboarding I accept two pair for
lives like really really cool days but
then I got a really good pair of snow
pants to wear like I don't really don't
need two pairs a long job so matter how
how cold it gets um like knocking on
what cuz I'm just envisioning next
winter like you're getting down to Lake
you know negative forty or something
they'll be regret in that statement but
but you know that happens great like
I'll go buy another pair of long johns
if I really absolutely need it I mean
they're not that hard to pick up um but
when it comes to like other hobbies that
I want to introduce them into my life
like I can tell you right now dude like
I've used to fish all the time being
from Ohio I mean there's just so many
opportunities whether it was like in a
nice big lake in Ohio or or a creek or
like my buddy he just lived in like this
trailer park that had a pond in there
and like we would fish for hours on that
pond
and I'd loved it man I somehow lost that
along the way like am I like when I
started my whole corporate career that
kind of fell by the wayside and I
remember like giving him all my fishing
stuff because you'd like kept calling me
for fishing trips and like I just you
know never really made it a priority but
I would love to pick up fly-fishing man
like living in Missoula Montana I mean
this is where they filmed a river runs
through it I mean like you you almost
have to fly fish if you live in Missoula
Montana right but I know that I've got
to say no to fly-fishing so I can say
yes to the other hobbies that I have so
I can say yes to going on tour so I can
say yes to so many other things so you
know I think where I would start if I
was you is what is like what is saying
no to being a part-time mechanic like
what does that open up for you and I'm
not I'm not like encouraging you to stop
working on cars but but ask yourself
that question like what would I do with
that time what would I do with that
space if I was able to say no to working
on cars like what would that make a room
in my life for and that's really kind of
how I look at my hobbies it's like why
would I say no to something and then
that's usually where I get the why and I
talked about that in the beginning of
his talk you know or I should say at the
beginning of his minimalist journey of
asking that question though you know how
am i how my life be better with less and
that's the same question you need to ask
yourself how might your life be letter
with be better with less hobbies and you
know what you may look you may ask
yourself that question and be like you
know what there's really nothing that I
would be able to do at that time any
better than what I do now but the fact
that you're asking us that question
tells me that there is something there
so I would dig a little bit deeper there
and just kind of look at it as a way of
like you've got to say no to something
so you can say yes to other things in
your life and what are those things that
you want to say yes to I appreciate it
very much thank you thanks Robin thank
you say that
hi I'm Ashley I'm from Coeur d'Alene
Idaho yeah love quarterly Rebecca the
drive over
absolutely it's quick and easy so thank
you very much Jessica was asleep when
when we were driving through Coeur
d'Alene I didn't want to wake her up but
like she's in the backseat just snoring
and Jeff handles all of our social media
and she also yeah ladies and gentlemen
Jessica Williams yes she also
straightens Ryan's hair like you said
you would never speak of that you feel I
should never speak of it oh I just want
to say thank you guys because it's nice
to see you guys get out of your comfort
zone I don't want to much find value in
that so thank you so I'm in a really
great part of my life where I'm kind of
being you know self reflective and
introspective and trying to focus on
relationships and so I'm curious about
your guys's take on the value you bring
to a relationship and what you do for a
person so for instance I've actually
experienced like a couple incidences
recently where it turns out that I might
not be providing as much value as I
thought I was summited and what's your
take is on that man that's super honest
thank you for that yeah and you don't
have to go into any more detail if you
don't want to but booking you is there
any way to expand maybe a little bit on
that so I can try to expand on that even
farther I think it's just kind of a
difference of what everyone else going
through in their life so I've recently
split from relationship and then it's
impacted a group of my friends and so a
lot of people thought you know that I
was a really good friend and then I
handful thought I wasn't so it's
interesting to kind of discuss that with
different perspectives and different
people in that group and so it's just
been a good part of my life to go okay
maybe I'm not bringing as much value as
I thought I was to these relationships
and so I wonder what your guys's take
was on that because you talked a lot
about value and what you do for other
people and I wonder like what I think I
bring to someone else's life may not be
as valuable to
I'm sure I wonder what you guys think
about that and maybe it can't be as
valuable either I mean I think that's
another important thing to realize there
are some authors who I've gotten a mint
value from there's no way I could
possibly pay them back so I want you to
realize a few things one is it's it's
not quid pro quo it's it's not well I
have to give one unit of contribution
and I expect to take one unit of
contribution from this relationship but
that said it does sort of work that way
I think every relationship whether it's
an intimate relationship of friendship
and acquaintance a networking buddy a
boss a employee whatever maybe every
relationship has what I would call an Us
box and it took me until I was 31 32
years old to to figure this out my first
sort of long relationship after my
marriage ended I realized something as I
was going through that it was a year
long and it was truly amazing it was
outstanding and then around the Year
mark it started to get kind of stale and
I found myself pulling away a little bit
because I didn't give it much thought I
didn't start celebrating on what what
the issues were or whatever I just said
yeah I well to get back to where I was
or maybe it's just comfortable now or we
start making up all these little excuses
in our head eventually it sort of
fizzled out it waned back and forth for
a while and afterward I did a lot of
that did a lot of reflection and what I
learned is that that relationship had
enough box and it was when it was going
really great I was giving whatever I
could give and she was also giving
whatever she could give to the
relationship and we were both taking
from that else box though taking what we
needed from that relationship and I
think both sides are really important
because if I just give give give give
give I'm going to feel worn out I'm
going to feel used as well I'm sure
we've all experienced this with some
sort of relationship where we have a
someone who always plays the victim role
in their life well victims become
victimizers and and what I realized is
it in a way after over time I was giving
less
and some little bit less three less
units of contribution this month or
whatever it may be right but I'm still
taking the same amount that I needed I
was taking what I needed and so of
course she had to give more and was
becoming more depleted and she felt used
and of course if you're just taking more
than you can give well then your
parasite right I mean it's by definition
that's what a parasite does it feeds off
of other living things and I was the
parasite in that relationship I didn't
mean to be and I cared about her and I
still think she's a great person but
what I realized from that is man I need
to be able to show up and give whatever
I can give and I also need to realize
sometimes I can give a whole lot more
than they can and other times I can't
give as much as they can give and I have
to be okay with that as well and so I
think remembering that is is critical
for any relationship even if it's just a
friend or an acquaintance realize that
do it an assessment or an inventory of
the relationship what am I taking what
am i contributing and then you can also
look at some of your relationships and
reprioritize them so just I hate to make
you run a million different errands here
but if you give her a copy of everything
that remains it's that second book that
we wrote but there's a whole chapter in
there about about that sort of journey
of discovering the the us box and in my
own life
yeah I mean just to expound and this
might be a little bit of an aside to
your question but to expound on the
whole unit keeping track of the units
like holding account is probably the
worst thing you can do in a relationship
like if I was to sit here and think
about every time like Josh and I had
some kind of disagreement ever since we
were fat little fifth graders I mean you
can only imagine like the feelings I
could probably bring up I mean we've
never gotten any like you know crazy
knock-down drag-out fights but I mean
maybe in high school like we used to
like play that you know like punch above
the waist and by me but you know that
was like kids being kids Ryan used to
beat my ass
yeah it used to no no but but in all
serious is like holding account even
with my romantic relationship with
Mariah like I don't I don't sit there in
like recall every time that she's made
me angry because if you think about it
let's say I did that with Mariah and she
did that with me we start off with Lake
this battery meter if you can imagine
like at a hundred percent and each of us
are like we're 100 percent of the
relationship and then I come home from
tour and I sit down and I don't like you
know hug Mariah right away or there's
something that makes her mad and that
100 percent meter goes down to like 98
percent and then you know she does
something doesn't make dinner right away
I would never get mad at her for not
making dinner right away I'm just using
an example here and then also I'm like
my meter goes down two percent and then
you know she gives me a kiss and then it
goes up one percent I mean always
keeping chocolate the problem is to get
that to keep that 100 percent is going
to be impossible and eventually it's
going to just it's a Net Zero game
essentially so you know I would first
say like don't don't try to keep track
of you know who has done what for whom
if anything I would encourage you to so
like with Mariah I'll stick with that
example um like I will ask myself on a
daily basis even if like I have done
something to really like you know make
her frustrated or angry at me
or vice versa um again like we don't
have fights but but even if it was a
that was a case I would ask myself like
what have I done today to add value to
Mariah's life like you know let's say I
am in this position where I'm like oh
you know I'm angry for these reasons
like I still would ask myself like if I
wanted to really maintain that
relationship I would still go out of my
way to do something to add value to her
life like how I showed her today that I
love her so I mean I would start there
but people who are really really
important in your life is asking if you
can't do it every day in the news every
other day like what have I done to show
this person that I love them and then if
all else fails you can always go to that
person and ask them like hey what else
can I do for you like I really want to
do don't even ask them like just just
tell them like I want to do something
for you tell me what that one
thing is or tell me two things I can do
to really help you out right now you
know to say I'm here if you need me I
mean everyone says that but to like to
go to them and like you know take as
much action as possible like that's
really going to show them how much you
care but yeah at the end of the day I
mean don't feel bad if you're not giving
as much as you'd like to or if you feel
like you're giving less unless they come
to you and say hey you're giving less
like really that's that's probably not
an issue like when it comes to like the
like the minimalists calm like you know
when I got it when I have to go to
WordPress and do something on the
website I'm like Colin Josh like dude I
have unlike a monkey on a keyboard like
I have no idea how to do this like he
definitely contributes more on that
stuff but at the end of the day you know
there are other things that I will I
will do for a dress that you know shows
him that I'm invest in this just as much
as he is so you know if they haven't
came to you and said you're not doing
enough then I really I wouldn't like let
that way too much on your shoulders but
if it really is then go to them and ask
them like hey what more can I do for you
I appreciate that thank you thank you
look howdy I my name is also James
I've lived in Spokane for about 16 years
originally from the East Coast and
definitely do appreciate you guys coming
out here that's such a beautiful drive
from Missoula even from Bozeman such a
such an amazing drive Josh you talked in
your monologue about those four boxes
that your mom kept and I wondered if
maybe you could elaborate on not knowing
anything about your relationship with
your mom but maybe if you know the lack
thereof or you know even kind of holding
on to those memories you know if there
is any gravity that that held to you
maybe you know you should have been
there could have been there and were and
your mom sort of gravitated to holding
on to these these memories because you
know as we grow
older we kind of I don't say abandoned
but maybe just kind of like you know
parents kind of good sort of you know
push to the side or we you know we have
our own lives
sure wondered if maybe you could
elaborate on that absolutely I if the
original Joshua fields Millburn writings
and I held on to those man yeah they're
going to be worth nothing someday I'll
tell you this I was when she moved down
there I was so [ __ ] busy that I didn't
I mean if I have one regret in life it's
I didn't spend more time with her
especially in her time again yeah for
sure I I feel that and and I didn't even
it didn't even come to my mind that I
should at the time that's how involved I
was in the minutiae of the unimportant
and when you it when I look back in and
now and it's the the meetings and the
being unlike my blackberry curve someone
that this one collapse at the blackberry
curve because they still they still have
a blackberry curve well I I mean so I
would get you know 250 emails a day that
required a response and at one point I
managed 150 retail stores and that all
seems so important to me at the time
well I remember when you like want to
take off work to go spend time with your
mom like how much of a hard time our
bosses gave you man yeah I mean I want I
took a I'm going to take a week of
vacation this vacation time it wasn't
and my boss is like must be nice
you must be a dick I mean the funny
thing is like I didn't have the balls to
say that at the time and now I have no
problem saying now whatsoever like but
but I think the reason the reason that
she held on to that stuff had little to
do with hers in my relationship because
she's been holding on to that stuff
since elementary Lewis literally sealed
since elementary and it moved from house
to house to house and I mean you all
have experiences right where you have
those boxes that you move and the next
time you're going to move you still
haven't opened the box that you move it
was essentially the same thing there
with her did we spend enough time
together no I mean I think our
relationship was pretty strained
especially growing up she was she was a
really bad alcoholic and I had a really
shitty childhood and and I I wouldn't
say that I resented that in fact now I'm
great I didn't really know how poor we
were growing up because you don't know
when you're in the middle of it I know
it's like a fish doesn't know what water
is it's just it's just there and and so
I found that that as I as I did sense
myself from that I didn't actually
distance myself from it because I I got
the corporate job who started making
good money I was spending even better
money and so really all I was doing was
repeating bad decisions so we didn't
have any money growing up and we weren't
happy we could but had there wasn't a
direct correlation there we were happy
because of repeated bad decisions and
money just amplified those bad decisions
in my 20s including and especially not
being able to spend enough time with her
when she needed it the most
yeah I still I still think about that
now thank you guys thanks James
howdy we're going to do we're gonna do
one last long-winded one and then Ryan
and I will will battle it out up here
okay hey can you hear me okay
my name is kami kami thank you
we saw you earlier today yes I bought
that rope yeah once you talk about why
we came and saw you earlier well I'm
still learning but Spokane has the Jonas
project and the Jonas project helps get
young girls particularly out of sex
trafficking and so they've started a
kind of pop-up sale that's going to be
happening in Spokane periodically to
raise money to help fund these safe
houses I'm probably doing a terrible job
of explaining it feel great but I'm it
was inspired through your podcast my
friend Billy kind of I think was the
spearhead for that and she just decided
let's get rid of our stuff to help fund
something that's going to help women and
girls yeah yeah you guys are awesome you
guys are so awesome
I mean they literally you should have
seen all the things that they had and it
was all like started through the 30-day
minimalism game it was yes it's really I
mean honestly like that's why Josh and I
do this look she came up she can explain
it better okay go for it
she's good guy she did really good okay
so a designer in might in a train maker
creative which is Sophie's here wherever
Sofia's said you got to see the
minimalism documentary
Toby's Adams wife right yes Adam is be
doing sound on life tonight so if you
laughed at my joke when the lights went
out earlier I figured Adam was right on
cue so thank you so much Adam giving a
round of applause anyway so I watched it
she was right I loved it and started
following you guys and watched you know
learned about the minimalism game with
this Jenny when you get rid of one thing
day two two things and then by the end
of the month there's five hundred things
and gone and so I just posted on
Facebook that I was going to do it and
then 14 other people said they were
going to do it and miraculously we were
also looking for a way to find the donor
project and so it just all kinda kind of
came together and we said oh my gosh
that's 75 hundred items what are we
going to do with all that and so anyway
you guys thank you I love it no thank
you
like that's like I said that's why Josh
and I do this like if if we can inspire
those types of actions and communities
everywhere and we do soocer an example
like that is that that is HUGE thank you
guys for pulling together and doing that
yeah it's beautiful
kami I'm so sorry to be really
requesting more important okay so the
thing I my first world problem is paper
I have a forger file cabinet at home
it's a piece of paper her hand right now
right I guess grab the shredder hang on
so this is my chicken to get in I I
didn't know how to like keep it on my
phone I think you just screenshot it but
I didn't know that so I printed it and
then I forgot it my husband happened to
be home and I didn't know how to get it
to me sounds like honey can you use our
landline fax machine and just fax it to
my work well what's it what's a fax
machine okay right so
so now you know what you're dealing with
right so like this is me I'm like
between Gen X and Millennials yeah but I
I feel more like baby boomer as far as
technology I have so much paper and I
don't know what to do with it and I I
don't trust like I have tape over my
computer camera
I've never Skyped like I don't I don't
know what I just think all the cloud
I've heard of it you know and here's a
gray like the thing is like I text I I'm
actually a real estate agent I know how
to get electronic signatures I keep my
paper footprint as low as possible but
how do I actually manage the important
papers in a way that you know
conspiracy-theory Jane here like feel
good about I gave her a DVD earlier
today oh these people know I it I think
one of the big problems that we have in
today's world is we're overwhelmed with
the the bad decisions of yesteryear and
I don't mean like actual like terrible
decisions I just mean like I'll just
stick this receipt in this drawer to
deal with it later
the reason Ryan literally had 7 junk
drawers is because when junk drawer
number 1 filled up it was it just was
forgotten and then you move on to junk
drawer number 2 and I know this because
I did the same thing right and my junk
drawers were a bit more orderly there
I'm really OCD and and and still though
like we hold on to these things why yeah
I was going to ask you like what what
papers are you holding on to that you're
like I got it
gotta have these papers I'm just curious
just create a couple examples a couple
example or just water I know someone's
kind of like sentimental medical records
okay wait a minute
here's Josh you remember that time I had
appendicitis yeah I just see I took a
picture of the appendicitis and I let me
get rid of it no it's funny like
actually at that you you just
Illustrated a great example like if we
say something out loud we realized how
absurd it becomes right because there
are times where I'm like I couldn't live
without this t-shirt but as soon as I
say that out loud I'm like get the [ __ ]
out of here and I mean like but that's
like I used to go shopping as a hobby
you know 93% of teenagers with shopping
at their favorite pastime we have more
shopping malls than high schools in this
country and we talk about we have an
education problem I mean I think we have
we have an addiction problem as well a
bad habit problem and I think that have
it extends over into keeping these
things and the question I was asked
earlier why do we do that it's just in
case I'm going to hold on to this just a
case it's generally not per sentimental
reason reasons and and so I'll talk to
you about delineating the to if it's a
just-in-case item meaning I might need
this someday in some hypothetical future
then give yourself permission to let go
of it because the truth is that over 99%
of the things you're holding on to just
in case you'll never need at all now
Ryan and I came up with something called
the 20/20 rule it applies to physical
items but I'm sure would apply to
paperwork in at least most scenarios
2020 rule anything you're holding on to
just in case you can get rid of in
replace for less than $20 in less than
20 minutes from wherever you are now you
might say well Josh that is a rule of
privilege I don't have to go every day
and spend $20 to replace all my just the
case items between the two of us we've
had to use that rule five times in the
last five years and that's a hell of an
insurance policy right there we lived in
the middle of nowhere
Montana Phillipsburg Montana if anyone
is familiar
oh wow okay you've been to the candy
store or you've been to discovery which
actually is pretty the taffy is
delicious
but no I mean what it's one-stop lay
within how many miles when we live there
I know there was one stoplight in thirty
four hundred square miles and like that
rule held up even in that town of like
eight hundred and seventy like four bars
one church town yes four bars four
churches if it means that in the summer
time I think the population increase a
little bit but but yeah I mean just to
this point of like that rule is it's in
this society even in the middle of
nowhere it still holds holds pretty well
is one last thing I will tell you that I
think is even more important especially
for paperwork you're Ryan earlier talked
about his packing party do you know why
we call it a packing party because what
party at the end of anything Ryan shows
up and shortly after the packing party I
had something called a scanning party I
got yeah there are beer there are nice
nice digital scanners out there right
now I tagged you go to the minimis calm
slash scanning you can see the exact
scanner that I use and that we share
actually all of us share we pass it
around and what you'll do is you take it
it's not those old scanners used to lift
up the lid and put a piece of paper on
wait 15 minutes to get a blurry
upside-down copy of something it's an
actual like use feed photos or documents
through it they scan relatively quickly
and what you do is you make a weekend
day of it or an entire weekend of it get
all your old photographs because by the
way your old photographs no one's
looking at them in the basement or the
attic or the closet right or even worse
if you put them in a photo album and
then force that onto your company they
hate that but here's the weird thing if
you put it in a digital picture frame
people were just drawing the screens all
of a sudden we like we start
congregating around this little digital
picture frame when you go to someone's
house and so you can do that now you can
even upload new pictures from your phone
play to the to the digital picture frame
without having to go through your
computer anything else what I'm going to
say is it's going to take you a day or
an entire weekend to do the scanning
party for all your documents and you're
going to realize how absurd holding on
to most of them or you're like I'm not
going to scan this one well then you get
rid of it and the ones you do scan now
you have it backed up now you said
you're paranoid as a cloud is terrifying
you don't have to use a cloud you know I
mean I use Dropbox personally and I know
that they're redundant insecure as it
can be for the cloud but I also have an
external hard drive you buy you know a
one terabyte hard drive it's going to
hold all your photos and all your
documents for a very long time and it's
probably going to cost you 60 bucks and
it that's worth a lot more to me so it's
on my computer it's on my hard drive my
external hard drives and it's in the
cloud as well so I have this sort of
triple redundancy but yeah go to the
minimalist comm flash scanning and
you'll see like the whole scanning party
thing there it'll help you out a lot
I'll tell you after the packing party
how so much fun I mean and after I went
through all my stuff and I had all that
stuff left over like Josh came over and
he's helping me just get rid of
different stuff like I remember I'm
going through like each box and I'm like
do I need this USB cable do any of this
and I see Josh and he's just like
sweeping things into like this 50 gallon
trash bag it is so much easier to get
rid of other people's stuff
and I'm like no dude I'm like I might
need that coffee mug that says world's
number-one dad on Italy like you know I
had 50 other coffee mugs but there was
like this the whole the whole
just-in-case thing like well what a 49
of them break and and you know Josh
helped me to kind of come up with this
rule where I'm like you know what if I
haven't used this thing in like the last
year I've got to be honest with myself
I'd be like am I going to use this
within the next year and if the answer
was no on both sides of that then I felt
comfortable either like donating it or
selling it I mean now I usually go buy
probably six months of it I mean that is
really ninety ninety days but like
what's snowboarding there's like a
couple things I have to extend that a
little bit there's always exceptions to
the rules right but I mean it helps me
keep keep a lot of the clutter out of my
life but I remember I was a like Josh
had left and I'd pretty much sorted
everything and I was kind of you know
doing the rest of my and I came across
this shoebox I had with a lot of like
high school memories in it like I had um
oh just like a picture of like me and my
prom dates and like a shot glass they
gave us for our senior year prom gift
which is like the worst gift you can
give it 18 okay and I remember there
were these letters that my mom wrote me
in high school and like these letters
like the the memory of those letters
like just thinking about just the
heartfelt things that she wrote in there
it really made it hard for me to like
just and I didn't look to those letters
and years it made it made it really hard
for me to just like get rid of that
stuff and I remember like holding on
that shoebox and I'm like you were
minimalist now dude you got to get rid
of this and I'm like going either like
trying to go to the trash can like I
can't do it like like this stuff really
means a lot to me so I got one of the
letters out and I read the letter it was
really weird like the memory I had of
the letter versus reading the letter
vocht two completely different emotions
the memory I had when I thought about
the letter was much stronger and it
meant much more to me than when I
actually read the letter if that makes
any sense and after I did that I was
like oh wow like this doesn't really
mean that much to me anymore like the
memory of him meant way more to me than
like what it actually said um I agreed
to like okay I'm just gonna I'm going to
snap a picture of it uneven scan it I
just like snapped a picture of it you
know why we had a listener that called
in recently you can do this there's a
new app now I think it's called
sorry to derail it here but it's a
couple that yeah it's called tiny scan I
think yeah they'd like to convert it
into PDF right yeah yeah and you know
it'll upload right to your computer or
whatever you wanted to do yes so I took
a picture of it so technically I still
had it and I threw the letter away and I
just thought to myself like worst case
scenario I can totally get that in the
morning like if I can't sleep at night
and I didn't even think about that
letter and so I want to take out the
trash the next night and it was like
sitting on top and I was like oh yeah
and after like realizing how it was it
was kind of important because I said it
was important and then I just kind of
like flip the switch and I'm like you
know what I'm going to read all these
letters I'm not going to hold on to
these silly high school memories because
they it's not that I didn't have a good
time in high school as much as I really
wanted to move forward with my life
rather than like live in my high school
memories and and I got rid of pretty
much everything in that shoebox well I
know I did get rid of everything but
like I took pictures of a few things and
that helped me out a lot I was going to
recommend like yeah there's little apps
that you can get to take pictures of and
upload PDFs but you got a fax machine
and this vaccine actually actually what
you can do with that is you can get a
phone number like a Google Voice I
haven't done this since like the
corporate days when we use fax machines
there but I know that still you can get
a phone number that you can fax stuff to
and it goes to your email so you really
don't even need to go by a scanning
device I mean less you got some pictures
you want to get rid of fax fax copy of
pictures are probably going to be kind
of crap but but just but just with the
the medical paperwork that you're
talking about I mean that stuff that's
that's a pretty easy fix and I want to
encourage you to do the same thing I did
like pull it up once the last time you
looked at it three three years ago okay
okay
so it is something that you look at a
lot great no I think that's I think
that's awesome
um I mean if you don't have three years
I thought she said three days three
years ago okay so you don't look at it
quite so much alright so those three
years ago then okay all right good good
my point is making sense then um but
even if you did say three days ago you
know what that is that's great like I'm
be glad that you're getting value out of
it but you don't have to have that
physical thing to like continue to get
value out of it but yeah if you even
look at it in three years I would
encourage you to go go through your
stuff and start looking at that and
really see what kind of emotion it
evokes when you look at it because I
guarantee you're going to experience at
least some of that what I went through
with the memory of it versus looking at
that piece of paper you're probably
going to have two different emotions
that that are going to be sparked um
here's the thing though you got a lot of
paperwork it's going to be hard this is
not easy I mean that's why and when I
give that talk I'm like I'm not talking
about a perfect life not even an easy
life because it's too often we mistake
simple with easy and simple is not easy
so I'm just trying to say with the right
expectation this is going to be hard
work and you are going to have to
formulate a plan but you've got to take
action on that plan but if you can find
your partner or a friend or a family
member who can come out it'll totally
help lighten up the load get a bottle of
wine make it a party but yeah I mean you
do have to take action on it and it's
not and it's not going to be easy it is
going to be difficult but what I'll tell
you is once you get through it you're
going to feel so much better and then if
you can come up with a system to keep
that paperwork kind of moving through
like with my taxes I do not have any
hard copies of my taxes anymore like
anything that I had from what do they
say six years is a hell for years I hold
on to six years I don't know what the
don't what it is
Oh Ryan we need your records from 2009
but but my point is is that if I but if
I needed that seventh year I could go to
my CPA at the time or my accountant at
the time or I think I was using like
TurboTax seven years ago and I know I
can log on to my account and get those
records um that is a at the CPA that I
use is it isn't just self-employed it's
a huge company I have I have email
records of it they have records of it I
have it in the cloud I'm sure I'll be
able to get ahold of it but but my point
is is that there are very few social
security card birth certificate passport
there are very few records that you
actually need to have physical copies of
which reminds me I lost my social
security guard again I gotta get another
one of those it was like a year ago I
have lasted the podcast what's that can
you wake laughter the podcast yeah wait
till after but but yeah I mean I guess
my point is my long point it's not a lot
of these things we do talk in ourselves
into needing physical copies of it and
in this day and age like we are in a
culture of access and things are much
more accessible than what they were 50
years ago so good luck on your journey
tweet us if we can help call in to the
podcast if you got any other questions
to come up but Cammy you got to
formulate a plan and you got act on it
thank you thank you all right before we
move on real quick for the people who
are listening at home or if you want to
pull your phones for some reason to do
this if you have a comment or tip for
anyone who asks a question today you can
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine or you
can also send a voice memo from your
phone you can email it email it over to
podcast at the minimalists comm we will
air our favorite comments and tips on
the next episode Ryan what time is it
you know I used to have fun with the
lightning round until you gamified it
but yes it is time for our hashtag ask
the minimalists lightning round we
usually do questions from Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook or at the
minimalists on all of all those
platforms and but since you're here
right now you can ask your question and
you will try it we'll try to give you a
short pithy less than 140 character
response that is tweetable by the way if
you're tweeting tonight or instagramming
or my spacing or whatever you kids do
these days you can use hashtag less is
now and will repost a lot of our
favorite photos and quotes and all that
other fun stuff
howdy what's your name hi my name is
Jessica and I'm from Alaska you should
totally go there by the way all we want
to you didn't come down from Alaska did
you no I did okay actually okay we've
been to all 49 states except Alaska so
Anchorage I see on our list one of these
days yes yes um I actually met you guys
out of the LA screening I used to live
in Los Angeles I was there for your
documentary screening Jame
cool um I was also the person who
collapsed about the blackberry curve I
used to be on my blackberry all the time
man I think that keyboard a that's the
only thing I really loved about the
iPhone but anyway um so actually was a
student out here at Eastern Washington
University back in the day whoo shout
out to the Eagles um
anyway I was working in Los Angeles the
last ten years and a friend of mine
actually turned me on to your podcast
and I wanted to personally thank you for
your podcast your blog credible
documentary thank you very much Alda
buck no keep going okay and everything
else that you guys have done um anyway
it really you know you asked the
question a lot what would you be willing
to give up to live a more meaningful
life and I always said that family was
my number one priority I was working in
a job that I absolutely loved as an
entertainment a publicist
however the job was incredibly stressful
but very creatively fulfilling however I
gave up that job to come back out here I
reconnected with my college sweetheart
so I gave it up to come back for love so
hope you mean especially partners out
there in the crowd oh yeah
congratulations um but my question for
you is I recently went back to LA to
meet up with some of my colleagues I'd
worked with I've heard you talk a little
bit about kind of leaving the corporate
ladder embracing minimalism when I went
back to see them there were a lot of
questions you know are you happy how are
you doing how is it
I was very exuberant however it was also
a little bit of a it was a little bit
strange you know because I felt like I
didn't want to come across as bragging
about kind of you know simplifying my
life feeling like I'm living a more
meaningful life how did you go back to
kind of communicate with your colleagues
after you left about kind of this new
journey that you are on in terms of
simplifying and really finding what
really matters without you know and
wanting to be kind of an inspiration for
them especially for your friends that
you stayed close with without kind of
coming across as being like you were
bragging how would you answer that a
tweety Ryan
um I got one for you go for it I like
that don't sweat the small stuff that's
good why is that thank you don't put the
small stuff so I'll get down to a
distilled answer here in a second uh so
no this is not fair you're not fair
Ryan life isn't fair you could tweet
that so so what I walked away from all
that and and the the relationships that
are still in my life from that time
which are very few are people who
eventually solve alight so how would I
tweet that Ryan I would say when you
walk away from everything the important
things follow okay thank you so much by
the way you all are the judges to
determine who wins tonight so I'll say
my tweet will answer and then I'll expel
because that's really how the game
should be played um
people hate change people hate being
changed even more so what I mean by that
is you know when I go talk to my friends
of yesteryear I don't put anything in
their face like I don't ever say hi I'm
Ryan the minimalist and what people ask
you what I do I go snowboard I'm like
what are you passionate about what do
you love to do actually that's really
what I'll say you know what do you do
I'm like I love the snowboard what do
you love to do and they're like uh I
mean like how do you make money I'm like
you want to know how I make money like
what an odd question
I think that's between but but you know
I don't I don't ever explain to someone
you know the minimalist lifestyle unless
someone is really digging deep and
they're really trying to understand like
okay what is it that that makes you
happy I noticed like you do things a
little bit differently tell me about
that but you know Josh came to me and he
was like hey man um dude you're a
hoarder just like me and you really need
to you really need to do this minimalism
thing um I don't think I would have I
mean I would listen to him I guess
because he's I've known for so long but
I definitely would have been like way
more defensive where when I went to him
and I'm like what is going on with you
man like you're really acting different
in a good way but like what you know why
the hell are you so happy and that
opened the door to that conversation so
yeah I would just encourage you to be
yourself and you know don't don't press
the whole minimalism thing on people
because again like people they hate
change but they hate trying to with a
when people try to change them even more
thank you thanks Jeff Thanks all right I
see four more we'll try to be lightning
fast Ryan I know though they want to
kick us out of here eventually so my
name is a Bobby and I I come from
Spokane okay how did okay and so my
question is I just recently graduated
college and so I'm trying to get you
know finances together and save up for
retirement or save up for a home
eventually and I've talked to a lot of
my and other friends who are also
looking at me buying homes or whatever
and a lot of them are like you know
willing to buy homes really soon you
know doing 30-year mortgage and stuff
and I've heard that you know you guys
have said no don't do that it's a
horrible idea
and I've you know told my friends this
and all my friends even their parents
that said that's you know they're like
oh that's a dumb idea because you can
pay off a thirty-year
or 30-year mortgage sooner and so I get
a 15-year mortgage when it's just going
to cost you like what if something wrong
happened and you can pay that 15-year
mortgage and so why not have a 30-year
mortgage where it's lower payments but
you can still pay it off longer I just
wanted to see like what you guys thought
about that because I just think that it
could be like tempting to just start
paying the minimum and then not getting
it paid off
soon enough so here's my my short answer
for you what percentage of people pay
off a 30-year mortgage in less than 30
years that's my short answer if I were
to expand it all on it I have a Ryan and
I wrote a long essay called financial
freedom five difficult steps to get out
of debt and and that's really what it is
difficult right I'll never go into debt
again and and if I there were if there
were some strange scenario where a
mortgage was right for me I plan to own
a home someday I can't afford to buy a
house outright certainly not right now
but I have a house fund that I continue
to save there are scenarios where it
might make sense if I could have at
least bare minimum 20% down personally
it'd be 50 percent because I want to be
a little bit more conservative with my
money but so 20% minimum and can I do a
at least a 15-year fixed-rate but for me
it'd be 50% down seven-year mortgage and
if I can't afford that that I can't
afford it so maybe that's my short
answer if you can't afford it then you
can't afford it
Bobby right yeah
Bobby there is no such thing as good
that I repeat there is no such thing as
good debt that's my short answer but
here's what I'll say about that uh there
are some that's better than others I'd
rather you go get a 30-year mortgage
than a you know sixty thousand dollar
credit card debt I'd rather you have
student loan debt than a you know payday
loan debt on the corner of the street I
mean there are definitely debts that are
better than others and I think some debt
can be used as a tool I think that you
know in Josh's scenario like that's
using debt as a tool to get a home and
you know not everyone can afford to just
buy a home outright I certainly can't
Josh can yeah like if I wanted a home
right now I'd have to I would have to
take out a loan same thing my my car the
roof leaks like when it rains I would
love to have a new car right now I'm
saving up for a new car but I get one in
the next couple years but I'm not going
to go out of my way to tack on that that
debt payment because that's exactly what
it is so like I live my life I keep as
many debt payments as possible out of
there now I've heard people be like oh
there's you know you can borrow you know
X amount of dollars from a bank at a 1%
interest you put in the stock market you
can gain X amount on the stock market
I've seen equations where people do
leveraged debt to make money the only
time I've ever seen that work though is
usually when someone is already well
enough off like Mark Zuckerberg took out
a mortgage on his house because he can
take a million dollars and put it in the
stock market and make you know 7%
year-over-year where his house he's only
paying 4% compound interest
year-over-year so he's gonna make more
money off having a million bucks so yeah
you know if you're well-off than great
like there's some some ways that you can
leverage that to make more money but
Bobby there is no such thing as good
debt
thank you thank you I think the lesson
there is if you're the sixth richest man
in the world you can afford to have a
mortgage howdy hi I'm Lisa
I'm from hopper Lake Idaho just over the
border
I was actually drugged here this evening
by my son his date kind of fell through
and I am totally new to this whole
minimalist thing so my question is more
energetic I know that you had mentioned
Fung Shui was kind of an inspiration so
I'm wondering how deeply you delve into
the energetic aspects of being
minimalist and giving up things that no
longer serve you and focus on the things
that add value to your life I ramble
here for a second to get my short answer
out I think that I think that there were
a bunch of unexpected benefits so my
short answers so at first me it was my
finances right because I had six figures
worth of debt half a million dollars we
count my mortgage my 30-year mortgage
and and so that was the first natural
benefit for me but from there was health
and repairing my relationships and
improving my relationships and growing
and contributing and finding out what I
was passionate about but also bringing
in a sort of aesthetic beauty into my
life and also a calmness and living not
stress-free but with less stress and
it's not about living a happy life right
I'm not happy perpetually I'm not a
manic person I'm happier and I think
that's important and I'm also not
chasing happiness anymore right and so I
think I think the short answer to that
would be something like when you take a
meaningful path the benefits are
plentiful um I'll just give you much my
tweetable answer
physical things we have in our life so
physical is a physical manifestation of
what we have on the inside
beautiful Thanks
thank you all right last to here last to
we'll make it we'll try to make a quick
for y'all howdy good evening gentlemen
I've got it even good did my name's
Colton I'm from Spokane Washington
thanks for being here thank you for
having me and thank you for being here
so my question does not revolve around
minimalism but humility so likes a bit
of a story my mother just sold her house
which is a big deal and the same week
she calls me and she says hey would you
guys like her would you go like to go
through the minimalists I said sure and
this is big because my mom likes to shop
and she just sold her house so I thought
this is a good time for all of this to
happen but in true fashion she decided
to go out with a bang and she may or may
not have purchased a nine tickets
tonight we have three people in
attendance so how do you get up here in
front of everybody and stay humble
because I told her to get up here and
explain this situation and she
threatened to disown me so I may be out
of a will tonight but I believe it was
worth it to have an answer to this
question are you public speaker I did
graduate with a degree in communication
I can tell you've got you've got a
confidence about you that I don't think
I'll ever have and so maybe that's part
of it
there are three things that I hate
travel public speaking in large crowds
of people
doing really well tonight um no I don't
actually hate those things I they they
make me uncomfortable like I'm a pretty
good writer and I know that and and so
it's harder for me to be humble about
something like that except you know when
I look at the work of someone like David
Foster Wallace or Mary Karr and I'm like
oh that's a dream and so that's one way
to stay humble but also I found another
way for me to stay humble and so this
would be my lightning round answer to
you is to stay humble constantly put
yourself in a state of discomfort I'll
just speak to the nine tickets and by
the way thanks for buying nine tickets
that's awesome Josh and I are not
allergic to money I mean it was not on
my dime so now what I'll say is the
people you love and the people that you
want to see a video support them no
matter what and just to expound on that
a little bit um you know I stay humble
by by learning from my errors and I
still err like I wish like again I wish
I could be like this minimalist thing
you just buy our books and watch our
documentary and you'll have a perfect
life that just doesn't work that way but
for me staying humble is admitting when
I've screwed up and learning from that
thank you both thanks promise thanks a
lot
hi guys my name is also James but my
question the bird how can we help our
children to relate and to encourage them
to get rid of their stuff that's not
important important to them when
sometimes what they're holding in their
hand at that time might be the most
important thing in the world to them at
that moment thanks know uh Ryan you
don't have kids can you answer this one
yeah it's really easy to give advice
when you don't have kids let me tell you
now I'm going to steal a coil from
Joshua Becker's book clutter free
clutter free with kids as parents you
get to set the boundaries for your
children and what I mean like here's one
boundary um and I'm totally stealing
this from a parent who was at one of our
events she was talking about how she
hates to tell her kids no so she's got
like a little five-year-old who will
come home and be like hey I got this
painting I just didn't you know class
today can I put it on the refrigerator
and she's like yes you can't put that on
the refrigerator then they walk over
there and like the refrigerators already
covered and her other paintings so she's
like which one do you want to take down
a throwaway it's like the kid will pick
like this one so then like they replace
it and they walk over the trash or throw
away so you can still tell your kid kids
yes but as a parent you get to set the
boundaries my short answer for you is
your kids are watching and doesn't
matter what you tell them honestly I
mean it's important to tell them the
right stuff but if you don't back that
up with the right actions I notice it
all the time with Ella I mean
when she's doing something that's
obnoxious or rude she probably got it
from me and she's doing a three-year-old
version of it so it's more obnoxious and
more rude but but but the truth is that
she learned it from somewhere and I
think that's actually good news because
that means that we get to if we're
aligning our actions with that best
person that we want to be and it keeps
me on my toes as well like if I know
she's watching then I better be the best
version of myself if I want here we go
if we want our kids to be the best
version then we need to be the best
version of ourselves thank you guys
thank you
you know what we on our podcast we often
do a added value segment where we talk
about some of that has added value to
our lives recently and I think maybe
we'll switch it up a little bit into a a
local added value segment since we
travel to Spokane quite a bit yeah you
have a local added value ah yes the
coconut burger at huckleberries yeah oh
my god we will like we all really earn a
little I'm like aw can't wait to get
that coconut burger and josh is like the
last three times I've been here they've
been out and I was so sad and yeah I
went there and like we asked and they
totally happened that yeah out of this
if you haven't had it it is out of this
world it is better it's the best
vegetarian burger I've ever had in my
life I'm not a vegetarian anymore but it
is the best vegetarian burger I've ever
had in my life I actually am tempted
because we live only like three hours
away from here they said because they
don't sell them in the store but they
said if I like purchased a case of
coconut burgers in advance they were met
on the zone they've been they would set
them aside for me ya know I don't think
I'll do that but uh but Dan that's a
good burger yeah I was going to
recommend core coffee but they went out
of business
and I know we've got my reality today it
was I was I was so disappointed but I
was one of my favorite coffee shops in
the country honestly and there they're
gone but I have another recommendation
the very first time I went floating was
it float Spokane and so yeah if you
haven't done sensory deprivation yet
it's it's it's worth the trip I totally
thought you were talking about going in
the river on the tube I'm like we live
in Missoula Montana where a river
literally runs through it and the first
time you've lifted anyway sorry I
digress I'm digressing I would never do
that disgusting my water has to be
sanitized was Alan ated yeah so exactly
96 degrees that s Rebecca yeah it's the
same temperature as your skin and so
it's sensory deprivation you can't see
anything you can't feel anything and you
can't hear anything and you realize how
loud your mind is once you've turned all
your other senses off and it is it's a
truly amazing experience so I would
encourage you to check that out real
quick we'll move on to 2 right here
right now we'll talk about what's going
on our lives we're on tour did you know
this so we just had a few weeks off from
our first little wave and we're out on
the second wave now we're in Spokane
we're headed over to Seattle and and in
Portland yes we were just in Portland
Maine and now we will be in Portland
Oregon and we're headed like 40 cities
total so if anyone's listening it's a
home and wants to come see us you can
it's less is now.com that's the address
over there also Ryan and I are building
a new podcast and video studio we want
to do a lot more video work we found
that a lot of people got a ton of value
in the documentary that we put out there
and so as someone like the documentary
and good thank you
and so we we just started something
called a patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
living wage because he has a wife and
three kids and and then also to hire a
full-time filmmaker so we can do a lot
more great meaningful video content so
that's something we'll work on if you're
interested in helping out with that you
can go to patreon.com/scishow to our
website and click on a little donate
button up there if you want to help out
one other way to help out if you can't
afford to help us out monetarily if you
want to leave a review on our podcast on
itunes
let's see is there anything else that is
going on in our lives right now I don't
know you want to talk about the other
cities that we're going to be in oh no I
don't have my whole list with me right
now okay
we're getting a lot more cities well
every time we get on like a facebook
live or like Shawn wakes up to 100
emails people are always like when you
come to presume when are you coming to
wherever is which is home which is how I
am yeah for anyone at home you just go
the blesses now.com and you can see
exactly where we'll be when we will be
well before before we wrap up I just
want to thank a few folks real quick
first off the venue just all the folks
here Darrell and then Jeff from Live
Nation the promoters of our tour I just
want to say thank you for letting us
this is such a beautiful space theater
thank beautiful
most important I want to thank you for
being here you could have chosen to be
anywhere else and you decided to be here
tonight and we're grateful I know there
cost some money to get into these events
Ryan and I don't really make any money
from touring because of all the travel
and we bring other people with us and
everyone else we have to pay but that we
have to charge so that we can afford to
have a place like this we can't try to
drag all of you into a field somewhere
and talk but it actually cost you a lot
more than money it costs you your time
and attention and we're really grateful
for that and if you leave thank you I'm
seriously I'm grateful that you decided
to come out here it's really
unbelievable that we get a chance to do
this and it's something we really
believe in and and I'm just glad and I
think if you leave here with one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
all right yeah we'll see you out there
shortly we love you Spokane thank you so
much
[Applause]
my name is Craig I'm calling from the
Toledo Ohio area and my comment is for
Susan who was wondering about keeping
baby clothes
to remind her of when her newborn came
home this I'm sure will certainly expand
into other projects and papers and
artwork as the child progresses from
preschool through kindergarten up to
four fifth grade when most of that
artwork is produced we kept a lot of
that stuff all of that sort of thing
went into a big box because at the time
when they're very young that seems like
very invaluable stuff to keep and
ultimately as the children grew older we
started to sort through it and realize
that only certain pieces meant something
or that we had something that we really
liked and those were items that got
scanned or photographed and even now my
children are 16 and 19 and as we still
find various things they kind of look at
it and say I don't know how you're
keeping that and so then we take a
photograph of it and then it goes in the
trash so they don't seem to mind at all
and we keep remembrances of the pieces
we like the best in the digital format
and the rest of it goes away so I guess
what I'm saying is give yourself a
little permission having a baby is a
very exciting thing and as they grow up
you will find more value in certain
things than others and the things that
you seem to want to hold on the most
right now may not seem as important in a
few years so give yourself a little
little time and a little availability to
kind of hold on to stuff for a little
while but not forever
hey Josh Ryan my name is Zach Miller
calling from Minneapolis Minnesota just
listen to your podcast site I'm not sure
if it was on clothing or travel or
something like that but you've mentioned
clothing and just figured I'd share of
what I've learned about my clothing
choices on my journey to becoming a
minimalist my three objectives for any
sort of clothing item that I would own
is that it is functional it is durable
and it is stylistic stylistically
versatile meaning I can wear it to any
or most of the activities that I would
partake in
I generally stick to neutral or earth
tones this way it gets rid of the need
for brands or logos and I can again
pretty much wear it anywhere pop and
color every once in a while with an
outerwear maybe a rain jacket or
backpack or something like that helps to
identify that it's yours as well which
is a useful function and again mostly
what I wear is geared towards function
what will I use it for can I use it for
many different things whether it be
professional business or going on a hike
hi my name is pepperoni I'm from Dallas
Texas and I'm 15 years old
I am a young student who's in high
school and I've just been using this
minimalist for about three years now and
I've gotten a lot of value from Yale's
podcast and everything but I wanted to
give a comment - how about fellow young
people and also fellow artists something
that I've noticed from a very young age
I've always kind of been a maximalist
and trying to fill up every wall with
every painting in canvas I create but
sometimes that motivates me and
sometimes that almost deteriorates my
function and my motivation so something
that I recommend is try going through
your artwork and and firstly scanning it
all because that portfolio that you have
it's in the Cameo alliums valuable in
the future but I would also reach out to
friends and family and although giving
material gifts at times can cancer
someone I think that if you reach out to
them prior and say hey I have this piece
of art can I notice that you have it and
you all and you've been talking about
filling it up I think that giving that
creation to someone else adding value to
their life and adding value to yours by
having them view all can mean a lot to
most people
everybody's Joshua Fields Milburn and
I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalist I was just looking up the
dates for the second leg of the lessons
now torso so Ryan and I we are in the
middle of this crazy 40 city tour we're
doing a live talk about minimalism an
in-depth talk about minimalism we're
also recording a live version of the
minimalist podcast we're answering a
bunch of your questions in person and oh
yeah we dish out a bunch of free hugs
after we're optional hugs yes yeah we do
hand hugs too if that's your thing
whatever you like we were looking
forward to seeing you on the road you
can head on over to les is now calm but
here's the cities that we're coming to
for the second leg of this 40 City tour
we're going to be in Canada again oh man
I can't wait I love Canada we're going
to be at Toronto Ottawa Montreal
Vancouver Calgary Edmonton but then
we're headed to the east coast of the
United States we're going to be in
Philadelphia we'll be in Manhattan and
Brooklyn two stops in New York Leno
you've made it well we've never had a
stop in Brooklyn so that's pretty cool
yeah and then we'll be in Salt Lake City
Denver and Phoenix heading over to the
mountains and then we're touring
internationally we'll be in Texas where
we're going to be in Austin and Dallas
and Houston and then Nashville
washington DC atlanta and tampa we're
finishing off with the cell almost but
then there's no better place to spend
December than in Detroit and Milwaukee
wait who told you that our booking agent
Oh perfect yeah so we're going to be a
Detroit in Milwaukee that's we're going
to finish the less is now tour this year
Helen over to Les is now calm you can
get your tickets you can find the dates
the theaters and you can see us soon
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you were fine
without it
[Music]
every little singing that you got hey
every little thing that you you guys you
gotta reach for you got a glare oh I bet
that you'd be fine without so tear your
eyes
[Music]